years the media's told us that men get
paid way more than women for the same
work but when you look closely at the
details the differences tend to shrink
even disappear take google who's been
accused of underpaying female workers
but when they investigated this charge
they found once they indeed were under
paying men there goes another narrative
now this should be good news it's
progress for women right instead however
advocates and they're supportive media
simply say that equal pay must mask a
more hidden discrimination now why would
they say that two reasons one for many
advocates progress can be bad because an
end to inequality means the advocates
are out of work so their role is less
about helping people then ensuring a
livelihood
- you lose a villain every day it gets
harder to say men have an edge on
anything look at education more women
graduate than men look at workplace
death or injury men lead that by a mile
in fact look at all the grim stats from
heart attacks to suicides
- the ultimate gauge lifespan men are
screwed from top to bottom but in
today's media landscape gender progress
is a zero-sum game meaning to elevate
women you must hammer men and if you say
something like hey fathers matter that
has to be an insult to women so even
though we know both sexes complement
each other the media drives a wedge
between the sexes because it pays when
will it end as long as their salary
depends on conflict never had a little
problem there with your phone to
undermine my monologue I disagreed with
what I was saying and mean - what what I
was trying to find something that I had
emailed earlier to myself about
salesforce.com ah so salesforce.com
would there's a big 60 minutes piece on
them about six months ago right and they
had done an audit had found that they
were under paying women right and they
were shocked by this
so they undertook this effort to try to
make sure that they brought everybody
back up to parity and one of the things
that the CEO of salesforce.com said in
the interview was he encouraged every
company to do an audit like this yeah
and they expected that the results would
be that women were being underpaid
everywhere so Google thinks we should
probably do this now they have fewer
women working in engineering that's a
whole different problem we can talk
about that but I'm not surprised that
they ended up fine
because women have been doing a lot
better and there are more women managers
and there's more women on boards and so
I think that if more companies do this
they'd find that they probably have some
inequality I think that that's part of
it but the to me the larger part is this
70% of their workforce is male right and
so if you're a manager if you know
somebody comes to you and they're you
say hey there's a woman candidate guess
what you have some discretionary money
and you use the discretionary money to
sweeten the pot in order to recruit the
woman so that you can say to people hey
we have women who are working here
especially especially the case with the
stem field that should be the case right
but isn't that making the opposite
argument then that you used to say that
people would say well shouldn't a
manager of a company be allowed to make
a decision I think we need binders full
of men I have a few at home you know
Greg for me personally I think men have
really gotten a raw deal recently the
Cavanagh situation I think had a
chilling effect yes a man bun phenomenon
but that wasn't a good look the Gillette
ad really hurt my feelings yes I mean at
this point Dana I know makes more than
me there is a wage gap here at Fox we do
the equal amount of work maybe all these
narratives that we believe it or wrong I
mean maybe Trump is a feminist yes
maybe CNN is not faking he paid for his
sex
what what what to say that's it that's a
feminist move yes
he's Pro sex worker yes sir Kamala
should support Kamala I was doing so
well
Jedidiah with the scene you were doing
so well we're really D right
I was very quiet for a while now I don't
know I mean I'm very old-fashioned in
that when I think about if I were to
hire someone and I made a little list of
what I you know merit would be the
number one factor work background their
interview recommendations on the job
performance genders not on there for me
like I don't either you hate women no I
well of course the focus on you know
hiring a certain number of women are
hiring a certain number of men or
whatever it may be really if I was
staffing a company I would I would want
the best people for the jobs that would
be my main goal
why because I can pay them less what
kind of person are you Jesse all right
I'm getting out of this